if you struggle with anxiety with
depression if you have a hard time
getting out of bed in the morning
slithering is something I want you to
try it is a pharmaceutic therapy and
it's going to change your life it
changed mine I've been doing it for six
weeks so when you wake up and you feel
that heaviness what I would do
is the first thing I would do is I would
high-five my heart which I taught you in
the high five habit I put a hand here
and a hand here and I just say I'm okay
I'm safe I'm loved and that hand right
here and right here it just really
grounds me and it tones the vagus nerve
and then I think about the fact that I'm
about to Slither out of this bed I don't
want to Slither out of this bed I don't
feel ready to Slither out of this bed
this is not something that makes me
happy this is not something that I want
to do slithering out of bed in a moment
where I'm depressed grieving or anxious
because I know that I'll feel better
once I get moving slithering out of bed
is what I need to do
hey Tevin Carmichael and I make these
videos because in my first business I
was making 300 bucks a month I quit on
my business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today let's live
your best believe life and learn the
morning habits to start your day
productively enjoy
it would be mornings that I would use
the five second rule to initiate it so
you can count backwards five four three
two one you're under your covers five
four three two one and then I mean you
literally move
in inside the the direction of the floor
you just succumb
to the resistance and then you're gonna
move around and you know there would be
Moorings honestly in the past six weeks
that I would get to this point and I'd
want to crawl in a fetal position like
this and I'd lay there for a minute and
then the dog would come over and lick me
and then I'd move like this and then the
more that I did it
the less I would lay on the ground
I'd just kind of roll around and stretch
and then eventually when you're ready
whatever shape you want because it's the
resistance that you're feeling you get
on all fours and you just start to crawl
and you're staying low to the ground
because you're giving in to the
heaviness
but you're not throwing in the towel
you're moving with it
you're moving through it
and at some point as you're crawling you
will feel ready
to just stand up
and it's almost like
that sort of physical
moving moves all that resistance out of
you and through you in a way
that is
organic
it's doable
it feels like in a weird way it sort of
acknowledges and honors the depression
and the grief or anxiety or sadness or
overwhelm that you're feeling
and it's super empowering because
you don't have to feel energized or
motivated and there's a lot of mornings
where I don't
and knowing that I can use this
technique to embody and move with the
heaviness inside me
as a way to move through it and get my
power back it's it's absolutely
incredible habit number two is make your
bed with Lewis house I think this is
hugely important this is something that
my mom used to tell all tell me and your
mom probably told you growing up as well
is to make your bed and there's a great
book by William H mcraven that says it's
about making your bed and he is a Navy
Admiral that talks about if you want to
live a great life make your bed and this
is a massive number one New York time
best-selling book this speech went viral
online and it's something that is so
simple but sometimes we think about
we've got to have some complicated
morning routine that you know biohacking
everything we can in order to optimize
our day and really when we go back to
the basics that's when you start to
transform your life everything goes back
to basics
so make your bed first thing there is
there's something that happens and I
started doing this years ago there's
something that happens when you decide
to take pride in your personal space
when you decide to say okay I slept here
I slept here for uh you know six seven
eight hours and I want to make sure I
have a clean space when I come home at
night
by doing that you set yourself up for
Success you accomplish something first
thing in the morning you build momentum
and you create pride and confidence in
yourself because you did something for
you you did it for yourself so when you
come home at night you can say wow the
time and energy I spent early in the day
paid off for me tonight now I can go to
sleep in a restful space so something to
consider try this for a week make your
bed every morning it's the last thing
you want to do because you want to get
up you want to go to the bathroom you
want to brush your teeth and you want to
get on with it but I'm telling you if
you take those two three minutes you
come back at night you'll be proud of
yourself
for what your past self did to help you
in the future
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there habit number three is use the 20
20 20 formula with Robin Sharma let's
talk about the 5am Club specifically I
love the subtitle which is own your
morning elevate your life so is this a
practice for you that you had not only
experienced for yourself in the
transformative nature of it but clearly
you've taught it to other people were
you like goodness If people could just
get this one thing you know obviously
there's so much more in the book than
just the 5 a.m Club idea which I want to
do dive into but there's something I
mean that's the title of your book so
was this practice itself so transformed
maybe like this is what the next book
has to be about absolutely I have two
children Colby and Bianca and if there
was one morning Rich if there was one
habit or if there was one piece of
advice not that they listened to my
advice but if there's one piece of
advice I'd ask them to listen to It's
rise before the sun there is a reason
many of the Great women and men of the
world the great history makers the great
poets the great philosophers the great
movement makers Rose before the sun
there is a magic in the air at 5am and
that's why the 5am club is so
transformational because because it's
the time of greatest quietude and I
believe Tranquility is the new luxury on
our planet it is that a time of intimate
creativity because you've just been
rested your brain is fresh there's
there's latest there's there's very
recent cutting-edge science coming out
now when you sleep your brain actually
has a mechanism to wash itself when you
wake up in the morning your willpower is
strongest when you wake up in the
morning you've got a full well of mental
focus and we know that focus in our
world is even more valuable than
intelligence and I could go on and on on
the benefits I mean you get up at 5am
you've got the world to yourself there's
no crowds you can think you can plan you
can care for yourself in a world where
so many people are so depleted and so
the five it the 5 a.m Club really is a
game changer and then it's not just get
up at 5am and you know scratch your
stomach or stare up at the ceiling or
look at your phone or look at especially
not I believe you can play with your
phone or change the world you don't get
to do both yeah and so uh it the 5am
club method is based on the 20 20
formula I'm happy to get into it but
that is yeah tell us what it is that's
the revolutionizer and and it started
from my experience with working with
many billionaires I've I've coached many
of the most successful financiers and
Times of industry for for over two
decades and one of the things I would
run them through is the way you begin
your day sets up the way you live your
day and so the 20 20 20 formula that the
book is based upon is pretty simple I go
into great detail in the book but
essentially it's from five to five
twenty the first pocket is move and I'm
a fanatic about neuroscience and why do
you get up and move because you're going
to release serotonin which is going to
make you feel better you're going to
release dopamine which is the pleasure
and inspirational neurotransmitter
you're going to release norepinephrine
which will boost your focus you'll
promote neurogenesis Marie you can
actually grow new brain cells and
increase your metabolic rate so the way
you begin the way you feel when you
first wake up is not the way you're
going to feel at 5 20. Second pocket of
the 20 20 formula 20 minutes from 5 20
to 5 40. that's on reflection so a lot
of us are busy but what's the point of
being busy if you're doing the wrong
things the the billionaires the great
creatives the people of great impact the
people who live Beautiful lives are very
intentional they're very deliberate
they're very conscious so for 20 minutes
you're right in a journal you can
visualize you can pray you can meditate
you can simply contemplate how you're
going to live your day what you want to
stand for during the day for example and
then the final pocket of the 20 20
formula is all about grow and that's
where you you just read from a biography
or a business book or philosophy book or
a I watch a marietv well especially
watching TV yeah of course that's the
game changer isn't it and so that's 20
minutes of growing because I think we're
most alive when when we are growing yes
and I believe the leader who learns the
most wins so that's in a nutshell the 20
20 formula habit number four is keep
distractions away with Brendan burchard
we've studied over 2 million data points
from 190 countries around the world to
understand what do high performers do
what are their habits what do they do
what do they focus on what's their mind
like not just like how do they show up
but rather what are they doing willfully
and on purpose and one thing they are
not doing is starting their day in
social media almost none of them but
think about what that will is it's like
you wake up you grab the phone uh you
start scrolling through psychologically
what is that doing for you first social
media is triggering in your mind the
comparison frame
you immediately start comparing oh look
at her ABS oh look at his thing oh he's
got this look at their followers I don't
have that impact I wish I could be like
this I want to be like that you're
immediately comparing your life to other
people what else you're doing you're
scrolling and as you're scrolling
neurologically we know that as doing the
reason you like to scroll so much and
swipe so much and move so much through
that phone is because every time you do
it fires off in your brain something
called novelty and when we have
Novelties something new to look at our
brain likes it and our brain says well
let's give them a little dopamine a
little vasopressin let's make them feel
good and so oh the more I do this the
more your brain goes distraction yay
look new things and you're swiping
through this and as you are swiping
through all of this you are forgetting
your life and your day I mean imagine
would you ever tell like a middle school
kid hey what I want you to do uh kid is
wake up every morning and immediately
start thinking about how the other kids
in school are and start comparing
yourself to everybody
no one loves us as adults we teach small
children to start their day comparing
themselves to other people and yet
that's what you're doing when you pick
up that phone what you're doing is you
are neurologically training your brain
to be rewarded by comparison and
distraction because right think about
the anchor here wake up grab look scroll
and what is that doing it is training
your brain first thing in the morning
check out of your life and check into
other people's lives
every morning you are training your
brain to check into other people's lives
not carefully and strategically and
intentionally think about yours
so what that means is if your person
who is checking your phone first thing
in the morning going through social
media You by definition by checking into
other people's lives comparising
yourself to other people's lives you are
ultimately training your brain
neurologically to live other people's
lives to see life from the perspective
of other people's versus your own Vision
your own dream your own thoughts your
own strategy your own intention
you are training your brain to live
other people's lives
so that's the worst thing you can do
please be thoughtful about this and I
know I know many like but it's hard
Brendan I just love to pick up the phone
I know I know because that's an
addiction
every time you do something if you have
to do it every day and it's something
that you do every day that is leading to
a negative result that's an addiction
and you must teach yourself to break
that you must not do that I had to
personally I literally do not have my
phone by my bedside like when I had this
I noticed I was like gosh I check in
I've seen the results I've seen the
studies why am I doing this so I turn my
phone off I put it in the kitchen
counter charging and I'm in the bedroom
sleeping which is really important right
to keep you sane so I think it's just a
change the worst morning routine we can
have is to merely be in the day in
comparison and distraction and habit
number five the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is heal your
mind with Joe dispenza I got run over by
a truck and a triathlon in 1986 on a
biking portion of the race I broke six
vertebrae in my spine and I was told
that I'd never walk again and so the
typical
surgical procedure for multiple
compression fractures with cord
impingement is this surgery called
Harrington around surgery and in my case
they were going to cut off the backs of
parts of my vertebrae from the base of
my neck to the base of my spine and then
they screw in these long stainless steel
rods and when you screw those rods in
into the vertebrae it acts like
cantilever it lifts the spinal column
off the court
but the prognosis was I probably
wouldn't walk again and um and that the
surgery was was hopeful that it would
give me some relief and and uh I think
if it was any other patient Louis
besides me I probably would have
recommended the surgery but this was me
sure and I just couldn't rush into it so
I had four opinions you know from four
of the leading surgeons in Southern
California and they were adamant that I
needed this circle all four of them all
four of them yeah in fact the the
medical director of Scripps Hospital at
the time was my it was my surgeon
and he was he thought I had a head
injury or he thought you know that I had
PTSD that I wasn't just following his
instruction
anyway I decided against the surgery and
I thought well listen I'm not going
anywhere I'm not doing anything I'm
basically laying face down and I thought
well
there's an intelligence that's giving us
life that's keeping a heart beating and
digesting our food it it really knows
how to heal way better than me
this innate intelligence is what's
giving us life and I thought well if
it's an intelligence it's it's a
Consciousness and Consciousness is
awareness and awareness is paying
attention so it must be paying attention
to me so I said look maybe I'll just
spend the rest of my time
trying to connect to this intelligence
and give it a plan give it a design give
it a template and when I was really
present and complete with that design
I would surrender this creation to this
greater mind and allow it to do the
healing for me and the other thing I
said is I'm not going to let any
thoughts slip by my awareness that I
don't want to experience now that sounds
really easy right when but when you're
faced with crisis or trauma we tend to
focus on what we don't want to have
happen instead of what we do have want
to have happen so I started on this
journey I've decided against the surgery
and um
it was a big revolution at the time and
I went through six and a half weeks of
hell I just could not get my mind to do
what I wanted to do because I'd start
reconstructing my vertebrae and imaging
an outcome and then I'd start thinking
I'm going to be living in a wheelchair
or why I sell my practice so you were
thinking about the way you wanted your
body to look and feel in your mind I
reconstructed every single in the moment
yeah in my mind I wanted to show it
exactly three-dimensionally in your mind
in my mind you're not drawing it out or
no in my mind I was reconstructed you're
visualizing visualizing and I wanted to
say look take a look at that because
this intelligence is always present
right so we got to be present with it so
I'd start off reconstructing my spine
and then I'd be like oh gosh um should I
sell my practice what if I live in a
wheelchair practice Chiropractic yeah in
the Southern California
so uh I couldn't get my mind to do what
I wanted to do and then after six weeks
I just went through the whole thing I
felt like I hit a golf ball right in The
Sweet Spot something clicked and from
that point forward what took me two and
a half or three hours to do I was able
to do in 45 minutes I was firing and
wiring you know these new circuits and I
was practicing paying attention
and then all of a sudden I started
noticing dramatic changes in my health
like this
and the moment I started noticing
changes in my body what was going on
outside of me and I started correlating
at what I was doing inside of me now I
was just hooked and I just started doing
with more passion and more sincerity
anyway back on my feet in 10 and a half
weeks back training at 12 weeks back in
my clinic and um and I just made a deal
with myself that if I was ever able to
walk again I'd spend the rest of my life
studying the Mind Body Connection and
mind over matter and then that led me to
just stop everything in my life I just
wasn't the same guy I had just been
initiated into something and
sold my practice sold my home sold it
all moved to the Northwest and I just
started asking bigger questions like who
am I what is why am I here what are we
doing and what happens when we die and
how did how did all this happen for me
what was the process I started studying
the science behind it and I couldn't
find it in any conventional textbooks
because this was unconventional right
and miraculous is kind of unconventional
so I started studying quantum physics
and Neuroscience and
happy genetics and it started making
sense I started building this model of
understanding then I asked the
fundamental question has anybody else
done it so then I traveled to 17
different countries and interviewed
hundreds and hundreds of people with
serious health conditions that were
treating either conventionally or
unconventionally they were staying the
same or getting worse then all of a
sudden they got better so what was the
cause that produced the effect you know
and the stories and what I learned was
so amazing I went back to school and
studied Neuroscience because mind was
such a strong element it wasn't diet it
wasn't celibacy it wasn't any of those
things it was just really this element
and so then I was able to
figure out that there were four common
things
and then I wrote a book about it and
then I thought God if this works really
on people that were sicken or better and
they come from all walks of life all
colors all Races all genders the sexual
preferences but all of a sudden
I wanted to see if I was able to
reproduce it
so then I started seeing okay let's see
if we can teach this be able to
reproduce the outcome because that's
science right so we went through about
what were the four common things the
first one was that there they all
believed and accepted that there was an
intelligence that lived within them that
was giving them life and these people
you interviewed who had had injuries
that overcame no no these were people
with cancer Ms lupus Parkinson's disease
who got better yeah just spontaneously
and it's called the spontaneous
formation
so I was I believe there was an
intelligence there was some invisible
life force that was they were connected
to that they felt like they had lost
their connection to they became separate
and disconnected from and that when they
got the diagnosis they woke up and said
man I gotta connect again and I gotta
connect to my Essence and so they
developed the relationship with it just
like you developed a relationship with
anybody it takes time you got to be
present you got to connect you got to
experience you got to be present all of
these things are important elements so
so that was the first thing
um the second thing was that they
realized that it was the mismanagement
of their emotions and the hormones of
stress that really began to create their
condition now now stress is when your
brain and body are knocked out of
balance the stress is when your body's
knocked out of homeostasis we have an
innate mechanism in our body that
returns us back to order so then if
you're someone cuts you off on the LA
freeway you have a emotional reaction
but 15 minutes later you're back to
driving and you're over it right that's
all organisms in nature can tolerate
short-term stress but when it's all day
long all week all year so if you're
reacting to like a Tyrannosaurus Rexes
chasing you you have to make a decision
am I going to use 20 of my energy I'm
gonna use 100 so it turns out when
you're reacting to traffic 200 all right
or if you're reacting to your co-worker
sitting in the cubicle next to you right
you're you're turning on that response
and what was once very adaptive becomes
very maladaptive because when you turn
on the stress response and you can't
turn it off now you're headed for
disease because nobody can live in
emergency mode for that extended period
of time well human beings we can turn on
the stress response just by thought
alone you can think about your problems
and you're producing the same biological
effects so those chemicals
give the brain and body A Rush of energy
and people become addicted to that Rush
of energy so now they use the problems
and conditions in their life to reaffirm
their addiction to that emotion they
need a bad job they need the poor
relationship so that means they become
addicted to the life that they don't
even like why do we need the bad job or
bad relationship and stay stuck because
it's a conditioned response so listen if
you get angry at a co-worker and all of
a sudden you get an arousal in your
brain and body right you get a rush of
energy
when you start noticing that your body
starts dropping your brain starts
noticing your energy starts dropping
you're automatically going to have the
image of the co-worker in order to what
give your body the natural the jolt
right so all of a sudden people become
addicted to their own thoughts right so
these people realize that oh my god um
I I I've been mismanaging my attention
and energy and I gotta I gotta get
beyond my past I got to get Beyond these
emotions I got to make some big changes
I gotta break the habit of being myself
you know I gotta stop being this person
now that sounds really good
theoretically and philosophically but
change is such a hard thing all right
because the moment you come back to your
senses and you step back into your life
and you see that person or you go to
that place or you're with that
experience so many people
are unconsciously reacting in their
thoughts and feelings to everything in
their environment so now their
environment is controlling how they
think and feel so they realize that in
order to change it'll change the
environment they've got to be greater
than their environment greater than the
conditions in the world but in the
circumstances be mindful that every time
okay I'm gonna think differently right
I'm not going to react that's right I'm
not going to go back I'm not going to go
back because the moment you start
reacting emotionally emotions are a
record of the past and if those emotions
are driving your thoughts you're
thinking in the past and if you can't
think greater than how you feel and you
believe your thoughts have something to
do with your destiny you're creating
more of your past right so it turns out
that the repetition of thinking and
feeling and feeling and thinking these
Loops that people get caught in
condition their body to subconsciously
become the mind of that emotion which
means now their body is their
unconscious mind is believing they're
living in the same past experience 24
hours a day seven days a week 365 days a
year what's the relevance behind that
well the latest research on genes says
genes don't create disease it's the
environment that signals the gene that
creates disease the emotional
environment or the physical environment
your environment any environmental
reaction but if you're reacting
emotionally to your environment the same
way
you're signaling the same gene in the
same way and now you're headed for a
genetic Destiny so the hormones of
stress push the genetic buttons that
create disease if you can turn on the
stress response just by thought alone
your thoughts could make you sick and if
your thoughts could make you sick is it
possible that your thoughts could make
you well so they began to realize that
oh my God the repetition of thinking and
feeling and feeling and thinking caused
me to feel guilt and I don't even know
it's guilt it just feels like me it's
just I'm used to the same chemical
continuity now the moment they decided
to change anytime you decide to change
and change anything about yourself get
ready because it's going to feel
uncomfortable you're going to leave The
Gnome yeah you're gonna leave the
familiar and you're gonna step into the
unknown even if the familiar is
uncomfortable and painful right you
still can be painful leaving the pain
right because some people are super
happy being unhappy right so then they
would rather cling to their suffering
than take a chance and possibility so
these people said I really have nothing
to lose right
so then they said I'm willing to be
uncomfortable and be in the unknown and
it turns out that's the perfect place to
create from so when the body is
conditioned to become the mind then to
change is to be greater than the body
every day of Our Lives we live in a
world that is incredibly complex and you
have to remember we all have a two
million year old brain
and it's not designed to make you happy
it's designed to make you survive
so it's always looking for what's wrong
so why would we allow this to be because
it's just a bad habit and so we need a
daily practice and so I want to show you
how I do this for me and I want you to
create your own system based on it this
mind serves me I don't negotiate with it
remember I told you I don't say well
I'll do this well maybe we can do it
maybe we'll jump in the water now it's
like it knows I'm not here to negotiate
when I say it we do it
that's what we want to train ourselves
to do today whenever you want to make a
change or improve something
the first place you want to prove it is
in your mental emotional state
if you do something from a pissed off
state from an exhausted state from a
frustrated state from a weak state it
won't matter what you do the thoughts
are weak when you're in a weak place the
actions are weak so the first thing
we're going to do is I'm going to show
you a simple breathing pattern and the
breathing pattern if you're familiar
with yoga it's like Breath of Fire it's
similar to Breath of Fire and it's a
movement here what it's going to look
like is this you're going to sit up in
your chair with energy we're going to
raise our hands up as we take the air in
and then you're going to blow it out
only going to blow it out your notes and
we're going to do that over and over
again for 30 breaths you're going to do
this with your eyes closed then you're
going to drop your hands down Palms up
on your weight on your legs and you're
just going to feel whatever you feel you
might notice some tingling you might
notice a sense of peace
it might just feel relaxed and then
we'll do another three sets of ten
another 30 we'll relax and then another
so we'll do three sets of 30. three sets
of ten ten ten ten ten ten ten ten with
a break between them when you're done
with that you're ready to Prime because
it puts you in state priming is three
actions it's done in ten minutes you can
do more than ten and many of you will
enjoy it so much you'll go longer but
the reason I do 10 minutes of priming is
I wanted to come up with a daily
discipline there was no excuse not to do
if you don't have 10 [ __ ] minutes for
your life you don't have a life so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna do our
three sets of ten three sets of ten
three sets of ten then with our eyes
closed the first three and a third
minutes of the ten minutes is we're
going to focus on three experiences in
our life that we can feel deeply
grateful for three of them and we're not
going to think I'm like oh this this
we're gonna take them one at a time
spend about a minute each and step into
that moment in your life that you could
feel grateful for it could be a little
thing or a big thing it doesn't matter
what matters is that you go there you
know if I ask you what's it like to me
on a roller coaster and you remember
time when you're in a roller coaster and
you picture yourself in a roller coaster
over there you're going to give me a
very different feedback than if I get
you to imagine the moment you were going
over the edge and you're in the front
seat then you're going to show me a
different result you want your gratitude
to be in the front seat not an
intellectual gratitude out there so I
take three minutes
a minute each I come up with something
different every time I think of a moment
that I could feel so grateful for a
blessed moment a beautiful moment a
loving moment a sacred moment and I step
in and feel it and flood myself with the
Gratitude gratitude is the antidote to
the two emotions that mess up most
people's lives what are they anger and
what fear those are the two biggest
you cannot be grateful and angry
simultaneously that's the beauty of it
it's the antidote to anger you can't be
fearful and grateful simultaneously so
the more you cultivate and Prime
yourself for gratitude the more you can
push through anger and fear very quickly
and by the way when I do it
I usually pick two strong ones and then
I pick something really simple and I
make myself really feel the Gratitude
like the wind on my face or the smell of
the ocean if I'm doing it outside by my
house or the look on one of my
children's faces and I'll just fill that
up and the reason is
if all you do is get grateful about big
things you're going to miss most of life
after we do our breathing step one of
the three steps first the breathing then
the three steps one gratitude three
minutes roughly a minute each three
different moments you can feel grateful
for and feel it enjoy it savor it live
in it next three in the third minutes
second piece we're gonna do is you're
gonna feel the energy in you and do a
prayer or a blessing now I know many of
you are not religious I'm not suggesting
you need to be
but almost all of us know there's a
power in love
you know if God was love and we didn't
come up with all the other names for God
you wouldn't have much argument between
people so imagine that what you're going
to do is Imagine uh energy of God the
universe whatever you want to imagine
coming down into you like a white light
and breathing it down in through your
body down your legs into the Earth and
then coming back up and out again so
it's
and then comes back up
and you don't have to do this with your
hands but I'm trying to show you what
the feeling is and while you're doing
this what you're going to do during
those three minutes is you're going to
give thanks it's like a prayer saying
heal my body my mind my emotions
strengthen me make me the best I can be
strengthen my love my passion my courage
whatever it is that you value in
yourself and you feel that happening of
the three minutes I do that for about a
minute and a half and the other minute
half I then take that energy through me
and I send it in a circle around to my
children to my family to my friends to
my co-workers to my associates to my
partners to the people I meet in the
street to my clients and so it's taking
the energy and now you might sound like
woo-woo stuff but the idea of allowing
your nervous system to heal and
strengthen just the focus of that alone
for you is strong and sending to others
as well so you can think it's all
[ __ ] but try it and decide based on
the experience if you do it a while I
think you're going to find it'll deepen
that sense of gratitude because it
becomes not only gratitude but healing
is strengthening and a gift to those you
love the last three minutes I call three
to thrive you're going to think of three
things that you really want to
accomplish or achieve but instead of
like hoping it happens or thinking about
it happening you're going to step in
your mind and experience it as if it's
done you're going to see it or feel it
breathe it celebrate it like you've
already achieved the goal what you're
doing is training your reticular
activating system and we talked about
this the other day the part of your
brain that notices things when you did
you know before you bought that car
outfit you never noticed them now you
buy that car outfit those cars and
outfits are everywhere how come because
your Ras now that your own one says this
is important I need to pay attention to
this well when you get clear what you
want and you see it as done and feel it
and create it in your mind in your heart
and you celebrate it there's a sense of
certainty than there's your body and
your reticular activated system starts
to go to work on making it happen so you
spend a minute at each one of those so
basically three minutes each three and a
third minutes each and we're done here's
another massive Insight so I always
think about businesses levels right and
I also realize that as the media
landscape or the
um the particular vertical or industry
that you're building a business in is
changing that is a constant and it's
something that you can't control right
you just cannot control the things that
are happening in the world around us but
you can always control what you're
thinking and what you're doing in
response to it so all of my work Centers
inside this gap between what's happening
in your life and in your work and what
your reaction is to it and how you can't
control
the things that are going on around you
but you can always control what your
reaction is and that Gap there that's
about five seconds long when you start
to understand that you can change how
you think you can change your habits you
can change how you lead you can pivot
and change even the philosophy of your
company and you can do it through the
decisions that you're making and
managing your reactions you will become
Unstoppable so three years three and a
half years ago I got into the speaking
business
um because of the popularity of that
tedx talk that I gave and
um that first year I did
um I don't know I think was like 27
speeches the next year I did 87 last
year I did 121 I was the most female
speaker in the world this year I've
capped it at 80 and here's why I
realized just like you may be realizing
in your business whatever your business
is that there are aspects of your
business that you love and that energize
you and there are aspects of your
business that are depleting as hell and
that are old and that are tired and that
if you continue in that lane you're
going to end up 10 years from now in a
place that you don't want to be
it's so important for you to pay
attention to what's energizing you about
the landscape around you and about your
own business because that's the secret
to seeing around corners and so the
corner that I was seeing around is that
as an entrepreneur even though it's
wildly lucrative to do what I do just on
the speaking platform I mean anybody can
do the math on 121 speeches right and
the amount of money that I get paid to
show up and deliver a one-hour talk and
realize there's a lot of money here's
the problem it's a terrible business
because you can't scale it other than
raising your price or raising the number
of of times you do it and guess what
else you have to show up
and I can't sell it so I found myself in
a situation where I had built a
multi-million dollar business highly
profitable and it was depleting the hell
out of me and I can't really scale it
and I can't sell it terrible position to
be in in an entrepreneur so I made a
decision that I you know what was it
Beau that actually energizes me about my
business and I answered it with the
first question it's hearing from people
I would rather answer comments on
Instagram all day long than stand in a
stadium with 5 000 people in it I get
more from the one-to-one connection
that's what fuels me and so I had this
light bulb moment paying attention being
clear that wait a minute I don't want to
build
the biggest speaking platform and I
don't want to build a coaching business
I want to build a Content company I want
to go back to my roots and build a media
company and so with that Insight I now
have to change right because the kind of
business woman that runs a
multi-multi-million dollar
speaking business where it's just you
and your speaking management firm and
your travel folks and your Logistics
people and maybe your social media
manager that's who's on the team the
kind of leader that runs that kind of
team is very different than the kind of
leader that is going to grow a hundred
million dollar Media company that's
going to Syndicate content every single
day that is going to own what she's
doing that's going to build Instagram
and Facebook and YouTube and Linkedin as
my personal ABC CNBC Fox and this is
what I want you to understand about the
story and that is this in order to get
to the next level in your business you
got to decide right now what habits do
you have as a leader that you have to
change now because you will not see
around the corner you will not engineer
that next Quantum Leap unless you
personally change and so one of the
reasons why I've gone from being the
most successful female you know book
speaker on the speaking circuit to
launching the number one book on all of
the self-publishing platform for Amazon
and one of the most read books in the
world and selling like gangbusters still
is because I am constantly innovating
myself
I know that I am the single biggest
problem in my company
and if I don't constantly pivot and
evolve how I lead and what I'm focused
on I'm gonna be the blockade and so you
know stop looking at what everybody else
is doing stop micromanaging the team and
ask yourself two years from now when you
think about where you want your company
to be what habit do you have to change
right now you wanted to be a
professional baseball player yeah right
yeah but then you got an injury I did
similar to me so you never made it to
the big league so did you play minor
league for a little I did yeah and I
played division one college baseball too
yeah I like every guy like you and I
talked about this last time it's always
our injuries that ended our careers I
probably it probably put me into a
premature place where I was going
anyways you aren't going to be in The
Bigs for I wasn't I played enough
baseball with guys who ended up in the
big leagues to know my limitations yeah
so like anything in life things happen
for you not to you that injury happened
for me it certainly didn't seem like it
at the time but it got me out of that
and into something like what we're
talking about now that completely
changed my life so yeah but yeah I want
to be an athlete for sure all my life
all your life that was my mask and then
when it exactly and then when it ended
your identity was like who am I right
yes lost yeah like a lot you and I were
just Thomas before we went on yeah you
know our professional athlete friends
were there career changes I went into a
like anybody like whatever your dream is
when the first one ends it doesn't
happen whether that be a relationship it
could be your marriage it ends it was a
dream right or a business venture or a
sport I went into a pretty good
depression and uh and how old were you
at the time 21 22 and I ended up you
know it's because people always see the
after like the house or whatever houses
or whatever the material things are but
I ended up bad man I ended up to press I
ended up moving back at home with my
parents I was living in the city I
remember I was living in this sleeping
in the same bed I grew up in with the
same teddy bear the same posters I was
like going back in time like six years
on back where I was totally unemployed
and couldn't find work didn't have the
motivation to get up and find a job just
sort of eating out of their fridge and
laying around all day so that's where I
was many many years ago after baseball
when you realize things in your life
happen for you truly especially in
hindsight everybody knows it in
hindsight right if you look back at any
disaster tragedy most people look back
five ten years later that happened for
me that was actually a good thing and so
I was unemployed I couldn't find a job
and my old man my dad was the best dad
role model you could ever have in your
life
hard-working man good man it's better
man than me it was more Integrity than
me he's the best man I've ever known but
when I was growing up my dad had a
drinking problem and so my dad had
gotten sober recently and he was going
to these meetings and he comes home from
one of his meetings and says there's a
guy at my meeting who can get you a job
that's right down the street in San
Dimas you're going to be working with
kids doesn't pay anything at six bucks
an hour but you're going to get this
damn job
so show up there tomorrow morning 8 A.M
ask for Tim so I walked I drive down
there it's a place called McKinley Home
For Boys little did I know that would
alter my entire life that was the most
significant thing that happened to me
and so I walk in there
I said I'm at mylett I'm here for the
job you're like what job I'm like I
don't know just my dad told me to show
up here yeah I need to ask for Tim
they're like
we have no idea who the hell Tim is
what's his last name I said I I don't I
don't know his last name and they're
like so you showed up for a job that you
don't know what it is and you don't know
who it is it's hiring you I'm like
here's what I know he's an alcoholic I'm
like oh dude yeah we know that too and
so they bring me to the guy and he says
uh you're hired let's go like literally
shakes my hand and you're hired and he
introduces me to these eight boys that
were my boys they were seven eight and
nine years old and basically I lived
with these boys these precious boys and
we ended up adding a few more my boys
were all Wards of the Court they were
all molested by Family more parents were
in prison and so they had no family and
so my whole life changed all of a sudden
these became on this 22 year old guy
these guys become my sons wow and I did
holidays with them I did birthdays with
them I lived with them literally in a
home or like a little dorm McKinley is a
massive campus full of children that
have been displaced from their homes
that live in individual like Cottages
like a foster care facility massive
though really yep all boys it's in San
Dimas here and um wow it just altered my
life man because I I'd been an athlete
had a huge ego had that mask I wanted to
compete I wanted to win I wanted
attention I wanted recognition first
time literally in my life I went
well I I love helping people I love
making a difference and my boys were
just come from horrendous situations and
so just I always say this all the time
and I have those eyes too you have them
I think sometimes kids who grow up with
some dysfunction they just have
different eyes yeah they just have these
eyes that are these boys all were
different but they had that same eyes
they just like man love me believe in me
you know care about me and I had those
eyes because I grew up in an alcoholic
family and my whole life changed I just
went wow I love I actually love helping
people and being involved in people's
lives I didn't know that because
everything was you're great you're great
you know what it is when you're an
athlete right everything's about you
you're amazing free dinners free this
you're a stud all of a sudden I was in a
stud and all of a sudden it wasn't about
me it was about these 10 boys that ended
up being 10 of them and it just altered
my life man and so after that I ran into
the financial business that I ended up
in but I would have completely flunked
out of that Financial business had I not
been with my boys for those years and I
was there for two years two years yeah
man like eight hours a day type of thing
or sometimes more sometimes 16 18. I I
think about I'm not kidding you I think
about my boys and my experience there
two of them are still very close with me
uh every day there's a moment where I
reflect on that it altered me completely
like what I wanted to do I always wanted
to be famous and Rich and successful and
now I just wanted to serve yeah I wanted
to help the little that I find out I
could get rich and famous and all that
other stuff I thought I wanted through
serving people one of the major major
Keys we found the first High performing
habit is seek clarity
and what we found is one of the
practices that high performers do is
they Define the feeling they're after
and so when we had to explain that and
later talk about it in the energy
chapter we had to differentiate between
feelings and emotions and they are
different emotions tend to be they're
the same yeah like we have they're
physical they're almost always automatic
even though in the brain is creating
associations has ought to happen for us
they just kind of emotion comes up yeah
you're watching a movie and you're just
sad and you're like oh my gosh you know
I'm crying you didn't even have the
tissues ready you're just like you know
uh but the feelings are usually
interpretations that we make of what
that emotion was and how it sticks and
the meaning we give it to it yeah and
the example I used to you know I like to
give and I don't remember if it's in the
book or not honestly because here's
what's happened this book is 400 pages
it was 1481 when I finished baby you
edited it down yes and it was 1481 good
complete like it was like awesome yes
but I was like that's gonna freak people
so we're publishing a bunch in academic
journals later and then stripped it down
to 400 pages so it's more readable and
fun and orientable so I can't remember
if this one actually made it in there
but
um the example I like to give is if you
want to go to a haunted house yeah which
I love I love them I love them and they
scare me the crap but if you and I walk
around you know you walk around on the
walls in a haunted house come jumps out
at you yeah you and I are both gonna
jump yes we are emotionally going to
experience fright immediately it's going
to be there right but I might be freaked
out for the next five minutes
and you might be laughing
why it's the meaning and the feeling
that we've defined it as
that's fine for everybody here's the
issue that people have and you have to
be careful about when we start talking
about energy because emotional energy is
real yes and that is look if at six like
we go to the haunted house at you know 5
PM in the afternoon
if at 9 00 PM now you're in your house
you're alone but you're completely safe
and you still feel scared
that's not the haunted houses problem
that is the way that you are defining
and working through your own emotions
you had the emotion of Terror and fear
and you're still experiencing that
feeling that's a mental job
not an emotional job so your job is to
go wow I'm at my house I've lived here
for 10 years I've never been threatened
this house this is a safe place I gotta
redefine the feeling I want to
experience and I work with one uh an
Olympic sprinter gold medalist Olympic
sprinter as a client and this person's
huge breakthrough
in getting better and going from
literally uh one Olympics before not
meddling at all to now gold I said what
made like what was the thing yeah and
one of the things they said to me was I
learned to define the feeling
and I said what do you mean by that and
he basically said you know if if if
there's a bunch of us at the starting
box and we're all in perfect Poise in
perfect condition the one to bet on is
the one that says this is the way I want
to feel in this race right now I know my
emotions are going crazy like my heart's
beating I can hear everybody I'm waiting
for that shot blast I can see my goal I
know how important this is and all these
um like these their emotions are there
yeah but that person is defining the
feeling going I'm going to feel centered
now
I'm going to get myself in the zone now
even though the anxiety is the emotion
of anxiety is there for all Olympic
level competitors all of them but they
Define that feat that emotion as a
feeling that helps give them a
Performance Edge
and I think that's important too you
know Bruce Springsteen says if he's ever
backstage and doesn't feel like nerves
he's going to hang it up yeah
but that's anxiety he's just defining it
differently there are three words that
are written on my phone
three words that every time I open my
phone I unlock it I see those words on
my background no matter what screen I go
to on my phone there's still those three
words remember your intention
remember your intention remember your
intention
I think one of the biggest problems
people have not just entrepreneurs and
people is
we don't set an intention we don't have
an intention we don't know what our
intention is and then for those of us
who do we just don't remember them we're
not consistent in remembering what what
we're doing and why we're doing it like
how many times have you gotten to the
end of a day or another week and felt
like you did so much but
it didn't but nothing seemed to move
you ever you ever got there you got the
end of the week like it's Friday
it's been a really busy week but what I
actually get accomplished and it turns
out not a heck of a lot
because it wasn't a lot of intention
I remember meeting Tom and Brendan at an
event in Puerto Rico at Brendan's home
and we're actually going to all connect
again in Napa coming up soon
and Brendan challenged me
on the first day to say hey remember why
you're here and you have to ask a
question
he says your problem is you're you're
always giving too much I mean it's
giving it's great it's not too much but
you're always giving you're always in
giving mode you're always sharing with
people how they can grow their channels
and have more you're always sharing
you need to ask
I need you to ask you have to make sure
that you sit here and you ask so when we
do a round table and I was really
insecure there's so many big names
um at that meeting that first one was
Tom in in Lewis house and Jay Shetty and
Russell Brunson and Dean graziosi and
Brandon burchard and Jamie crinlima who
just sold their business for 1.3 billion
dollars and all of these highly
successful entrepreneurs I'm sure I'm
missing a whole bunch of names uh
and I felt like what am I going to bring
to the table I mean I'm
I'm going to teach Brandon Bouchard how
to believe in himself more right I mean
they didn't it didn't feel like I
deserved to be there and so I was really
insecure about it and Brendan I got
there really was the first one there on
the first day and Brendan found me and
said hey
just make sure your intention today is
you you have to you're gonna give by
default so that's fine but you need to
ask for something that helped a lot that
shifted my intention away from just
being insecure about how to how to bring
value and also ask hey what do I need
what do I actually need out of this if I
had one question that I could ask all
these successful entrepreneurs what
would it be
and that allowed me to ask a better
question because I showed up with more
intention
and so I want to give you the tools in
this video to live a more intentional
life and just try to nobody's going to
be 100 consistent so how can you stay as
consistent as possible so we're going to
look at three different phases
there's three different versions of it
okay step number one is an intentional
life so we're looking macro now what's
an intentional life look like for you
what does that mean when I say
intentional life what does that mean
what what kind of Life do you want to
live what are your Ambitions what are
your aspirations what are your desires
what are your dreams what are your goals
what was it intentional life like if you
could actually plan your life where do
you want to be spending your time you
don't want to be on a beach all day long
you don't nobody does you want to feel
like you're doing meaningful work so
what does that look like
what what do you look like as a human as
a as a father or as a mother as a
husband as a wife as a son or a daughter
as an entrepreneur like all the hats
that you wear
what is an intentional life look like
for you in terms of the in terms of the
habits that you're doing right
what does intentionality look like for
you what does success look like for you
and getting clear on that because when
you have a map it's a lot easier to then
start to live it when you don't know
where you're going You're wandering all
over the place so what is an intent when
I say that what does an intentional life
look like to you what comes to mind all
the different hats that you wear and the
three easiest buckets are the
relationship their career or finance and
then your health those are usually the
three buckets that Things fall into so
what does an intentional life look like
for you
step number two is what is an
intentional calendar look like for you
so now that we have our life ideas in
mind what does that translate to on a
daily basis
so for example in my life Monday's my
mentoring day I Mentor the people that
are on my team and that I've invested
into their businesses Tuesday is my
YouTube day today's a Tuesday I'm
filming Tuesday I'm I'm doing all my
YouTube stuff I film videos I look at my
strategy I look at all my content all
the experiments and thumbnails and tests
that we're doing new ideas that's
Tuesday Wednesday is Project day and I
get to pick a project that I want to
work on that might be my book it might
be movement makers might be brand Linux
might be whatever project that I could
just be creative and spend the day
working on that project I think having
forced creativity in in little chunks is
hard I think to be creative and to make
something special you need you need
blocks of time so that's Wednesday
Thursday is my public face today that's
when I do interviews and podcasts and
Skype calls and whatever to help promote
the business people want me on their
shows and so that's all packed on a
Thursday I do my movement makers on a
Thursday I do my brand Linux on a
Thursday I need to show up for the
public so it's extrovert hat on and
let's go let's go beat the drum I
believe
Friday is my CEO day and that's where I
work on the big projects to grow my
business there's nothing scheduled on a
Friday
it's basically big big like Wednesday
with a tragic day but more like Hey how
do I
where am I trying to go what do I want
to accomplish what's missing in my
business in my life and just giving me
again even more
Freedom instead of structure to think
about where I want to go Saturday is fun
day and Saturday is the day that I spend
with Nina my family and whatever we want
to do no no chores no admin it might be
hiking it might be a new restaurant
might be some Festival just allergy
planned an entire Saturday full of fun
for us to do and then Sunday's family at
midday Costco grocery shopping cleaning
the condo
laundry like all the stuff you have to
do as a human
but it's not on Saturday right we're not
going grocery shopping on a Saturday's
fun day and then it all repeats and goes
back to the same schedule on Monday
that's an intentional calendar for me so
it's an intentional life of how I want
to live and then the calendar is set up
so that if I did these things will I get
closer to achieving the life that I want
success is the habits you can have goals
great but where is your where in your
calendar actually going to focus on
achieving your goals so when you set up
your intentional life great now let's
create our calendar so that those things
are there if you want if you have you
know health goals well where are you
going to be exercising and working out
where are you going to be spending time
to go buy the healthy food and the cook
the healthy food that you want to be
eating instead of not exercising either
McDonald's every night right because if
it's not in your calendar you're not
going to do it you can have the best
intentions but if it's not in your
calendar you're not going to do it so
you have to put it in your calendar in a
realistic way that you can stick to and
it's possible we're just not doing it
and so it remains as some goal I want to
make content I want to make a YouTube
channel great where in your calendar are
you spending making YouTube videos and
until it's in your calendar it's not
going to happen consistently it's going
to be too much off the whim of oh I just
feel like doing it today so I'm going to
do it if you wait till you have time to
do something you're never going to do it
so you have to schedule it intentionally
so level one of intention is an
intentional life level two of intention
is an intentional calendar and then
level three of intention is an
intentional day and even Moment by
moment in the day so
before I make videos today I'll ask
myself what what's my intention for this
activity why is remember your intention
on my cell phone because I want to start
the day looking at my calendar and
seeing how do I want to show up and when
I look at each individual task I ask
myself how do I want to show up how do I
want to show up for this video I want to
show up
inspired I want to help people believe
in themselves more I want to create one
of the best videos I've ever made I want
to have energy I want to I want to pour
light into people
so that's the intention if you if you
even just talk out the intention before
you do the thing
you'll show up better you'll show up
different you show up with that energy
that you wanted
essentially when you have to switch to
something else at 2 30 I'm going to
spend time with my wife and we're going
to go for a walk take the dogs now it's
you know nice sunny day here and in
Toronto we're gonna go for a walk and
that requires me to switch intention
then I'm going to switch back to making
more videos then I'm going to spend more
time with Nina over dinner then I'm
going to spend time with my son we're
gonna do some Minecraft uh it requires
it if I'm if I'm thinking about YouTube
videos while I'm having dinner with Nina
or playing Minecraft and hanging out
with my son
I'm not present for them
I might be there spending time but I'm
not really there
you can spend hours with somebody
watching a movie or lounging watching
Netflix but never actually connect with
them versus a 25 minute walk together
could be much more connection than most
people have in a week
so in order to do that it's you have to
switch to gears and just remind yourself
what's my intention for this and that
could take 10 seconds it doesn't have to
be this 30 minute activity every time
you switch tasks just how do I want to
show up for this when I have dinner with
Nina tonight how do I want to show up
I'm now making YouTube videos I'm
showing up as entrepreneur Evan changing
lives spreading believe spreading hope
inspiration positivity let's go
when I show up for five o'clock dinner
with my wife what how do I want to show
up I want to show up as a caring husband
I want to be supportive and just asking
myself that question forces me to be a
better husband when I show up for dinner
as opposed to still being in YouTube
mode
right see the difference and so it's an
intentional life
then it's an intentional calendar
and it's an intentional day and even
intentional moments inside the day so
you can look back and say I did five
different things today and I showed up
for all five of those as I wanted to
show up and nobody gets it perfect I
still don't get it perfect but even just
a reminder and the aim to get better
leads you to have a much more
intentional life successful life and
most importantly happy life
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
the powerful morning routine hack that's
easy to develop check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there music doesn't just affect you
physically but mentally emotionally
spiritually and physically and that's
why it's so powerful I didn't think you
know 30 years later now that I would be
proud to say I'm putting people